-Our next guest is a talented
actress who stars in
and executive-produces the
television series "The Great,"
which is streaming now on Hulu.
Please welcome Elle Fanning,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh! Hi, pal. Oh!
I miss you.
Elle, you have such a --
You have a glow around you.
It's like you're a --
like a beautiful --
-No, I didn't realize
this top is, like,
shimmering in the L.A. sun.
-Wow! You look like a fairy --
a magical fairy.
[ CHOIR VOCALIZING ]
♪ Ahhh ♪
Yeah, I love this.
Welcome to our show.
Welcome back. How are you?
How is the family?
Everyone good?
-Everyone's really good.
I wish I was there,
like, sitting on the couch.
It made me jealous
watching Kenan.
I haven't been to New York
in so long.
-Well, you'll get here.
-But I'm with family.
-Yep, very good.
Very soon, we'll do it.
Did you celebrate New Year's
with the fam?
What did you do?
-You know, we had some plans
that we actually --
we had to cancel, but we
normally go to my sister's.
And she has a party of some kind
with a bunch of her friends,
and I always go over there.
And this year,
she was super-excited,
'cause she came up
with this idea
that she was going to do
a fast-food potluck.
-Wait. What is this about?
I like the idea, though.
-Yeah, everyone was going
to bring a different fast food.
We had, like, Taco Bell,
McDonald's, Domino's,
Krispy Kreme, like,
and I was in charge of Popeyes.
-Oh, my gosh!
-I know.
It's so sad
that it didn't happen.
-Oh! I want to go to this party.
-Yeah.
-Next time you come to New York,
let's do it.
Let's just start one up.
Potluck fast food --
-Yeah, it's a cute idea.
We love fast food, so...
-I've got to do
the McDonald's, man.
I've got to do --
-Yeah, you bring the McDonald's.
-I'll do the Mickey D'S,
yeah, yeah.
Exactly, yeah.
-Cool.
You know,
I want to ask you this question.
This is a -- You know me.
I get down to it.
I want -- I'm hard-hitting,
ask the real questions.
And I want to know about this.
There's a rumor online --
look at this right here --
that on TikTok,
user6754189318472 --
fans think that that is you.
Can you confirm or deny?
-I confirm that is me.
-Wow!
It is you.
It's such a catchy --
Clearly, you're doing this
for the followers,
because it's such a catchy --
-I know.
It's so easy to memorize.
-Easy to remember,
yeah, of course.
"Oh, I'm user 67584--"
Yeah, exactly.
Why is that your name,
by the way?
-God, you know, I think in the
first lockdown, like --
I say "first lockdown."
But, like, right when everything
started, TikTok so exploded.
And I was with my friend.
He's like, "You should make one.
Like, let's see what happens.
Just do it.
Don't put a profile picture.
Just don't change the name.
And let's see."
And I posted,
and it kind of, like --
It got a lot of followers.
And, like, TikTok then DM'd me
on my Instagram
and was like, you know, "You've
surpassed this certain number."
Like, I was just doing it
as a joke,
but I don't know.
I post when I want.
But it's silly.
It's like little secret.
Not so secret, I guess, now.
-No, now it's out, yeah.
-Thanks.
-I want to talk --
Let's talk about "The Great."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's fantastic.
You are such a good actor.
Congrats on -- You're getting
all sorts of
awards and nominations.
Congratulations.
Season 2
streaming right now on Hulu.
Do you want to set up what's
going on in this season?
-Yes. This season,
Catherine has --
The coup has worked, and she's
successfully overthrown
her husband, Peter,
which is played by the amazing,
hilarious Nicholas Hoult.
-He is great.
-And now, basically,
I mean, the whole of Russia,
the country,
is on Catherine's shoulders,
and she has to learn how to be
a mother to a country
and a mother
to her unborn child.
She's pregnant
throughout the season.
-Yeah. You know,
you posted this online,
and I was like,
"What is going on?
And was this in the script?"
But can you describe
what's happening here?
You're pregnant.
-Yeah.
Yes, that is me doing
a backbend on set
with my bump,
which was incorporated
into the scene,
actually, somehow.
-How?
-They wanted to show kind of
Catherine in, like,
a fun way and they wanted her to
do a party trick of some kind.
And I was trying to come up with
what I could do.
So I asked Tony,
our showrunner --
I was like,
"I can do a backbend."
So they -- But he was like,
"Can you really?"
So, it preceded with me, like,
having to go, like,
do a show-and-tell to, like, the
props, the set, the costumers,
like, to see if I really could
and if it actually worked.
And, so, I was serving macaroons
on my pregnant tummy.
Fake pregnant tummy.
-That's crazy
how those things happen.
I know -- I heard,
at the end of every season,
you paint a portrait of you
as Catherine?
-I do, I do.
You know,
each film I've ever done,
every director
I have worked with,
I have given them a little,
like, drawing of my character.
So, I did this for
the director and Tony
on the pilot, actually.
It's, like, silly.
-You're very talented.
I love these.
-They're, like,
little cartoony, but -- Yeah.
-Do people, like, ask you to do
their portraits now?
Like, people are like, "Hey,
could you do one of me" or --
-Well, I guess I would be up
for the challenge,
but they all kind of
end up looking like me,
because I only draw myself.
-So if you did me, it'd be your
face in a suit behind a desk.
-Yes, exactly.
Little cropped, you know,
brunet hair, but my face.
So if you want that.
-Yeah, I do.
Who wouldn't want your face?
Are you kidding me?
Come on.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Elle Fanning in Season 2
of "The Great."
Take a look at this.
-How blessed we are by our Lord.
I bless Catherine the Great,
for she is our
new and rightful sovereign.
-You're calling yourself
"The Great"?
-Of course.
-Bow before her
in worship and praise.
-It seems arrogant.
-It is if you are not great.
If you are, it is just calling
things what they are.
-Right.
-Shh!
-I have a speech.
-Just put on
the crown on me when
the long-winded blessing stops
or I will have you
dragged out right now.
-You wouldn't.
-It would be embarrassing
for us both
and make it clear I took it.
So maybe it is a good idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Elle Fanning, everyone!
Season 2 of "The Great"
is streaming now on Hulu.